[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
gerade jetzt im sommer habe ich wirklich
immer lust auf etwas leichtes als er
gibt es heute einen sommerlichen
nudelsalat den könnt ihr warm oder auch
kalt essen könnte im sommer vorbereiten
es kann auch eine tolle grill bei lage
sein oder eben an einem warmen sommertag
eine schöne hauptspeise ich nehme dafür
heute vollkornnudeln mal gucken ob
demokrat auch schmeckt mir schmeckt sehr
gut und vor allem nämlich heute einfach
ein paar zutaten auch gleich noch aus
dem garten den rucola habe ich noch
nicht hier
ich nehme noch ein bisschen baby
spielplatz so und das ganze wird
wirklich super leicht ich nehme dafür 60
gramm pinienkerne rote zwiebel 30 gramm
olivenöl 400 gramm cocktailtomaten 200
gramm vollkornnudeln da habe ich jetzt
die falle
ich habe ich noch 100 gramm baby spinat
brokkoli hole ich gleich im garten
getrocknete tomaten etwas balsamico
essig salz und pfeffer und bing
mozzarella
ich nehme zuallererst die pinienkerne
kann ich nämlich in einer beschichteten
pfanne rösten oder sind so zweite
gefallen mir nicht so gut in dem schloss
die restlich kurz ist sehr schön farbe
bekommen haben und kann in der
zwischenzeit schon mal die rote zwiebel
schälen und in halb ringe schneiden
eigentlich will ich zwei nehmen aber die
ist echt groß deswegen nehme ich jetzt
nur eine
[Musik]
die hier einfach so ein bisschen
durchschwenken ab dem 2 dann kann ich ja
auch schon mal die tomaten halbieren
[Musik]
die sind jetzt perfekt die nehme ich
jetzt kurz raus dürfen abkühlen und in
der gleichen fahrer jetzt kann ich sie
ein bisschen höher wieder schalten in
der gleichen pfanne nehme ich jetzt das
olivenöl
da habe ich jetzt einfach das öl
genommen von den getrockneten tomaten
da ist er wirklich schon mega viel
geschmack drin deswegen braucht auch ein
bisschen weil das immer ein bisschen
flüssigkeit drin ist aber nicht schlimm
da kommen jetzt die zwiebeln dazu die
frage ich kurz ein bisschen glasig darf
man da einfach direkt den perfekten
geschmack drin aus den tomaten die habe
ich übrigens auch schon fein geschnitten
die gibt es auch schon geschnitten aber
ich hab selber ganz kurz geschnitten was
ich hier jetzt noch machen kann ist das
nudelwasser das habe ich jetzt auch
schon gekocht
da kommt jetzt alt sein und den nudeln
kann ich jetzt schon al dente abkochen
also wie auf der packung beschreibung
zehn minuten brauchen die jetzt bei mir
und weißt du was ich stelle jetzt hier
den herbst auf mittel hohe hitze
wir geben kurz zusammen rucola holen
okay ich weiß wirklich nicht was mit
einem schiff der rucola sieht traurig
aus aber es nicht schön
ich nehme einfach noch ein bisschen
sauer am vortag
[Musik]
kate zwiebeln sind jetzt auch soweit
rucola und der salafist auch gewaschen
hier gebe ich jetzt noch ganz kurz die
tomaten dazu einfach nur kurz mit
schwenken bei hoher hitze sollen jetzt
nicht weich werden sondern einfach nur
ein schönes intensives aroma bekommen
die nudeln brauchen noch knapp zwei
minuten
ich kann jetzt hier auch schon salz und
pfeffer dazugeben
jetzt kurzem essig ablöschen habe ich
jetzt einfach weißem balsamico ihr könnt
aber auch in anderen hellen essig nehmen
aber da passt schon ganz gut wenn wir
die terraner gericht jetzt nämlich auch
schon aus der pfanne rauskommen die
tomaten samt öl und essig hering kurz
die nudeln abgießen
wundert euch jetzt nicht über die menge
denn ich habe die ganze packung nudeln
gekocht aber ich nehme nur die 200 gramm
für mein gericht ich glaube ich nehme
doch 250 die hälfte der packung
es kommt jetzt hier direkt noch mit rein
zu kleben die nudeln nicht zusammen weil
ich jetzt hier drin habe denn es sich
noch drin hab das ganze kann jetzt kurz
durchziehen aber jetzt lasse ich gebe
noch die getrockneten tomaten mit rein
die sind auch immer so schön wird sich
aber jetzt lasse ich den salat abkühlen
denn ich möchte es nicht dass der spinat
und der salat feld und auch der
mozzarella soll er nicht schmelzen
also jetzt kurz abkühlen lassen und dann
muss ich eigentlich noch die zutaten
untermischen
beim aufräumen
jetzt ist er nur die salat schön
abgekühlt und jetzt gebe ich hier
einfach noch den blattsalat drauf das
heißt einmal hier baby spinat nicht
gerade normal gewaschen und tropfnass
gelassen denn ansonsten trocknet besser
schnell an der luft und den will ich
dann wirklich so kurz vorm verzehr
glaube ich schon unterheben dass er
einfach nicht so zusammen fällt dadurch
schmeckt eben auch frisch
okay da ist noch sehr trocken aber nicht
schlimm dann noch bisschen was von
meinem salat hier vom garten
einen ganzen krautgarten mal hier rein
aber ich muss echt sagen ich liebe
meinen salat hochbeet denn du gehst raus
mit seiner schüssel mit einer leeren
schüssel und kommt mit einer richtig
vollen bunt gemischten salat sowie
diesen diese salat typen die man kaufen
kann kann ich mir einfach raus auf dem
hochbeet machen also echt cool hier
lieber das reicht schon
ja und wenn es nicht unbedingt nur
pflanzliche egal sein muss dann gerne
auch etwas mozzarella dann nehme ich
jetzt den baby mozzarella und dann nur
noch untermischen
das ist mal ein sommer nudelsalat also
nudelsalat ist ja oftmals sehr schwer
und sehr sättigend weil viele noch mit
mayonnaise machen das ist jetzt sehr
leichte version für den sommer könnt ihr
gerne mal ausprobieren bei uns gibt es
den jetzt gleich zum abendessen und das
rezept gibt es auch sallys - blog.de
oder ganz einfach in einer kostenlosen
app da könnt ihr euch auch so wie auf
dem blog die rezepte hoch und runter
rechnen können zu speichern
eine einkaufsliste erstellen und an
eurem freund oder andere frau schicken
und dann hab da eben alles im überblick
viel spaß beim nachbarn und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]